Okay so Michael let's see if we can do something that
might be faster and just as good as what we've been
doing with value iterations. And what we're going to do is we're
going to emphasize the fact that we care about policies, not values.
Now it's true given the true utilities we can find a
policy, but maybe we don't have to find the true utilities. In
order to find the optimal policy. So, here's a little sketch
of an algorithm okay, so it's going to look a lot like value
to ratio. We are going to start with some initial
policy, let's call it pi sub zero and that's just
going to be a guess, so it's just going to be an
arbitrary setting of actions that you should take in different
states. Then we're going to evaluate how good that policy is, and
the way we're going to it at time T. Is to calculate its utility,
which I'm going to call U sub t. Which is equal to the utility you get by
following that policy. Okay? And I, I'll show you in a moment
exactly how you do that, alright? But I just want to make certain
that you, that you, you kind of buy that maybe we can
do that. So, We have, given a policy, we ought to be able
to evaluate it by figuring out what the utility of that policy
is. And, again, we'll talk about that in a second. And then, after
we know what the utility of that policy is, we're actually going to
improve that policy in a way similar to what we did with value
iteration, we're going to update our policy, Time T plus one, to
be the policy. That takes the actions that maximizes the expected
utility based of what we just calculated for [INAUDIBLE] of T.
Now notice it will allow us to change Pi over time
because image that we discover that in some state that actually
there is an action that is very good in that state.
That gets you some place really nice gives you a really
big reward and that went on and you do fairly well.
Well then all other states that can reach that state. Might
end up taking a different action than they did before, because
now the best action would be to move towards that state.
So these two steps will actually, or can actually lead to some
improvement of the policy over time. But the key thing here
is we have to figure out exactly how to compute u sub
t. Well, the good news is we know how to do
that, and it's actually pretty easy. And it boils down to our
favorite equation, Doman's equation.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So our utility at time t, that is the utility that we
get by following a policy at time t, is just well, the true reward
that we're going to get by entering that
state plus gamma times the expected utility,
which now looks like this. There, does that make sense? Do you see that?
>> Okay, hang on, it looks a little
different from the other equation. So did you
mean for it to have T UT is defined in terms of UT and not UT minus one?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, that's interesting. And the max is gone but
instead of max, there's a policy. Stuck into the transition function.
>> Yep.
>> A choice of action is determined by the policy.
>> Right. And that's actually the only difference between what we were doing
before is that rather than having this max over actions, we already know what
action we're going to take. It's determined
by the policy we're currently following.
>> Okay, but isn't this just as hard
as solving? The thing with the max, you said?
>> Well, what was the problem that we were solving before with the max?
>> That was the Bellman equation.
>> Yes, but we were solving a bunch of equations. How many of them?
>> N.
>> So we were solving n equations, and how many unknowns?
>> What's the difference between this, n equations and
n unknowns, and the other n equations and n unknowns?
>> Well, n is the same.
Mm hm.
>> There's no max, though.
>> There's no max. And what was it that made solving that hard before?
>> It made it, the max made it non linear. The max is
gone now. You're saying this is, this is a set of linear equations?
>> Yeah. Because, well, there's, there's just a bunch of sums. And the
pi is not like some weird function. This is just effectively a constant.
>> I see.
>> So now, I have n equations, and n unknowns.
But it's in linear equations. And now that I
have in linear equations and unknowns, I can actually compute
this is a reasonable amount of time, by doing
matrix inversions, and regression, and other magic hand wavey things.
>> That's very slick.
>> Yeah.
>> It's seems, it's still more expensive than doing the
valued [UNKNOWN], I guess. Yeah, but you don't have to, perhaps,
do as many iterations as you were doing before. So
once you've evaluated it, which we now know how to do,
and you've improved it, you just keep
doing that until your policy doesn't change.
>> Very cool.
>> Mmhm. And this does look a lot like value iteration to you, doesn't it?
>> Yeah, though is seems like it's making bigger jumps somehow.
>> It is, and that's because instead
of making jumps. In value space, it's making
jumps in policy space. Which is why
we call this class of algorithms Policy Iteration.
>> Cool.
>> Right.
Now, this inversion can still be fairly painful, it's, you
know, if we don't worry about being highly efficient, you know,
it's roughly n cubed, and if there are a lot of
states, this can be kind of painful. But it turns out there's
little tricks you can do, like do a little step
evaluate iteration here for a while to get an estimate and
then, you know, kind of cycle through. So there's all kinds of
clever things you might want to do, but at a high level
without worrying about, you know, the, the details of constants, this general
process of moving through policy space. And taking advantage of the fact
that by picking a specific policy you're able to turn your nonlinear
equations into linear equations turns out to often to be very helpful.
>> So, is it guaranteed to converge?
>> Yes.
>> Nice.
>> Well there, that was easy. I'm, I'm not going
to go into it but, you know, there's a finite number
of policies. You're always getting better so eventually
you have to converge. It's very similar to
the, or at least intuitively it's very similar
to the argument you might make for [UNKNOWN]. Cool.